[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime outpour and first off I want
to thank you all for the support and
positive feedback that you've been
giving us on the video ranking the
entire demon clan from weakest to
strongest that video was definitely a
lot of work and I was actually planning
to make it for a long time and I kept
feeling guilty for not making it sooner
so the outpouring of support really
means a lot to me thank you since that
video went live we've had a ton of
requests to rank the entire goddess clan
from weakest to strongest as well so in
this video I will be doing exactly that
always feel free to give me your video
requests either in the comments or on
Twitter and Instagram at anime uproar
and of course if you like this type of
content and you want to see more you can
leave a like to let me know and if
you're new to the channel don't forget
to subscribe and hit that notification
bell now we don't know quite as much
about the goddess clan as we do about
the demon clan the goddesses are still
very mysterious and very sexy
fortunately for this video the things
that we do know about the goddesses are
mostly related to their powers so we do
have a good idea of their strength and
combat capabilities just a quick warning
there will be manga spoilers in this
video a lot of the information that we
have about the goddess clan hasn't even
been revealed yet in the anime so we do
have to rely on manga material you have
been warned let's start it off with the
Druids now the Druids are human not
goddesses but they are a unique group of
humans that live in isolation inside the
forest and have a special connection to
the goddess clan members of the goddess
clan are known for a number of unique
abilities including the power to heal
the ability to fly the ability to purge
and destroy dark souls such as the souls
of demons and so on
the Druids worship the goddess clan and
they considered a demon clan to be their
natural enemy unlike other ordinary
humans the Druids are much more in touch
with nature with animals and with the
spirit world and they are able to
perform magical spells and techniques
that normal humans cannot these spells
include the ability
to heal as well as the power to destroy
dark and corrupt souls such as the souls
of demons and these are all techniques
that they share with the goddess clan it
is believed that these techniques were
taught to the druids by the goddess clan
as a reward for their devotion to the
goddesses fun fact Hendrickson was born
into the druid clan inside the holy
druid land of Ishtar before going on to
become a holy knight in the kingdom of
Leonys and Zara Terra's the former great
holy night is also a member of the
druids
although the goddess clan was on the
winning side of the holy war from 3,000
years ago they suffered tremendous
losses and in order to seal away the
demon clan members of the goddess clan
had to sacrifice their ability to
maintain physical form however at this
point in the story they can still
possess inanimate objects such as a
sword or they can use the body of
another living being as a vessel and
that brings us to Jenna hands Inari the
two of them are currently serving as the
leaders of the druids in the holy land
of Ishtar but there is more to them than
that Jenna is an Arri were actually born
as goddesses and they took part in the
holy war 3,000 years ago at one point
they became disillusioned with the war
and with the goddess clan so they
decided to escape they eventually
possessed the bodies of two twin human
sisters who by the time the goddess has
met them were too injured and
malnourished to be saved and so Jenna
and zan arey used these human bodies to
hide and escape the goddesses at this
point in the story they continue to live
as humans and serve as the leaders of
the Druids both Jenna Ann's Inari have
interesting powers and abilities such as
creating powerful illusions manipulating
lightning and as goddesses they are
thought to be capable of using ark an
incredible power which generates fears
and beams of light that can disintegrate
enemies and this power is especially
effective against a demon clan jenna is
an Aries highest recorded combat class
or power level is 3,000 for both but
knowing how the seven deadly sins series
works it wouldn't surprise me if their
true
was dormant and therefore far higher
than we think I mean just look at
meliodas and how much stronger he turned
out to be than it appeared at first
glance
and speaking of Mellie Otis it is worth
noting that Sunehri seems to have a
crush on him what is it with this guy
and the goddesses they can't seem to get
enough of him
he's like a goddess magnet at any rate
Jenna in Scenario appeared to be
lower-ranked goddesses and we can assume
that there were many other lower ranked
members of the goddess clan flying about
until they lost their ability to
maintain a physical form following the
previous holy war next up is jela met a
former divine lance corporal of the
goddess clan gentlemen took part in the
previous holy war and she is believed to
be the one who informed the goddess clan
that the goddess Elisabeth was having a
relationship with Mellie Otis the son of
the demon king after the holy war she
lost her physical body like the other
goddesses but eventually she managed to
possess the body of the troll queen she
brainwashed other trolls to help her
invade the druid holy land of Ishtar and
take control of a sacred altar and she
did this because the altar had a special
connection to the mysterious celestial
realm the homeland of the goddess clan
gentlement intended to use the altar to
free the goddesses and then get revenge
on Elisabeth Jenna and Sunehri whom she
considers to be traitors to the goddess
clan however gentleman's plan was
ultimately thwarted by Mellie Otis and
the seven deadly sins
we do not know gel emits exact power
level but we know that she had the
ability to use arc as well as breath of
bless which is an ability that only
higher-ranked members of the goddess
clan are able to use breath of blessed
bestows extra strength onto a person of
the goddesses choosing but it also
brainwashes that person into becoming
fanatically loyal to the goddess clan to
the point that they are even willing to
sacrifice their own life for the
goddesses gentleman is first introduced
in a side story called queen of the
altar which has so far been told through
extra material throughout volumes 23 to
32 of the manga and then we have narrow
basta she may not be best girl but this
member of the
as clan his definitely breasts girl I
mean seriously
feast your eyes you puny mortals like
jela met Niro Busta was also a divine
lance corporal during the previous holy
war meaning that she is one of the
higher ranked goddesses and she was
actually a direct subordinate of the
Archangel Ludo shell one of the
strongest and most important members of
the goddess clan after the demons were
sealed away in the coffin of eternal
darkness narrow bustah lost her physical
form like the other goddesses and she
was sealed inside a sword this sword was
ultimately used by denzel as he offered
up his own body as a vessel for narrow
bustah in the hopes that she would save
everyone from the commandments however
after easily killing a few lesser demons
Netto busta realized that she was no
match for the 10 commandments and she
tried to escape but she was ultimately
destroyed by derriere e of the ten
commandments it is difficult to say
exactly how strong the robusta is we
don't have an exact power level for her
and we don't know how strong she would
be if she was inside her own body rather
than possessing the body of a mere human
the same applies for the previous divine
lance-corporal we discussed gel abbot
who was possessing the body of a troll
but I chose to put narrow bustah ahead
of gel abet because narrow basta was a
direct subordinate of the Archangel Ludo
shell and she was entrusted with
guarding the gate to the celestial realm
during the previous holy war which seems
to indicate that the goddess clan had a
high degree of confidence in narrow
Busta's abilities now the goddess clan
is mostly made up of female beings as
the name would suggest but like the
demon clan and their ten commandments
the goddesses also have their own
special elite force known as the four
Archangels these four Archangels are
powerful angelic figures who unlike the
other known members of the goddess clan
are actually male first up we have the
Archangels Tarmey l and sorry o-tar meal
and sorry L are two of the four
Archangels and we have to consider them
as a pair because so far we've always
seen them fighting together as a sort of
dynamic duel along with the usual
goddess clan abilities such as Ark and
healing as Archangels Tarmey land sorry
L also
Grace's special powers created for each
archangel by the supreme deity herself
sarios grace is tornado the ability to
generate a fierce tornado around him
that can tear his enemies into pieces
and thar be Elle's grace is ocean the
ability to create a powerful ocean that
can be used to trap his enemies both
sorry el ant army all have proven to be
able to recover from heavy amounts of
physical damage and Tarmey all can also
turn his own body into liquid which
allows him to dodge attacks we know that
our meal and cereal are able to face off
against multiple Commandments at the
same time and in that sense they are far
beyond the power level of someone like
Nero basta although to be fair they
could not measure up to dairy Aryan Mon
speed in their indi reforms while these
two make a very strong team sorry el ant
army el are clearly the two weakest
members of the four Archangels next up
is the goddess Elizabeth the daughter of
the supreme deity and one of the
highest-ranked goddesses the goddess
Elizabeth is the original incarnation of
Elizabeth Leona's whom we meet at the
beginning of the series because she fell
in love with Mellie Otis the son of the
demon king Elizabeth was cursed by her
mother the supreme deity so that she
would constantly keep being reincarnated
as a human for all eternity and meliodas
who was cursed with immortality by the
demon king would be destined to keep
losing her over and over again
although the goddess Elizabeth hated
violence and although she opposed the
holy war
she is nonetheless one of the strongest
members of the goddess clan while her
abilities are not necessarily offensive
in nature they can still be very
effective for example Elizabeth is able
to face off against both Darian man
speed in their in their reforms and
purified them with her powers so that
they are knocked unconscious and turned
back into their normal forms instead of
killed Elizabeth also has the ability of
empathy which allows her to speak
directly to the hearts of her opponents
and make them lose the will to fight and
she was able to do this to an entire
army of demons the Archangel mile
compares Elizabeth's strength to the
strength of Mellie Otis and the
kinjal Ludo shell which in itself gives
us a good idea of just how powerful the
goddess Elizabeth was in her original
body however we don't have an exact
power level for her at this time next up
after Elizabeth is the Archangel Ludo
shell only in anime can a badass
overpower dude also be a top tier waifu
at the same time and Ludo shell is
living proof of that the leader of the
four Archangels Ludo shell is a ruthless
member of the goddess clan who wanted to
exterminate the entire demon clan during
the previous holy war he was directly
responsible for the deaths of many
members of the demon clan including
Derry Aries sister and in the present
time Ludo shell just happens to be
possessing the body of Princess Margaret
the sister of Elizabeth Leona's and the
highest quality waifu in the entire
series in my opinion I mean just think
about it Gil Thunder is a guy with pink
hair who is let's face it pretty weak
compared to the entire main cast of the
series and yet Margaret still loves him
she would do anything for him and she is
extremely dedicated to him if I were to
pick any waifu in the seven deadly sins
it would definitely be Margaret although
if I were to pick the hottest girl I
would totally pick derriere II impure
thoughts impure thoughts anyway along
with the usual powers that a high ranked
member of the goddess clan possesses
Ludo shell also has a grace called flash
which enables him to move extremely
quickly and makes him one of the fastest
characters in the entire series even in
Margaret's body Ludo shells power level
has been measured at 200 and 1000 which
is considerably higher than even the
highest ranked demons like Chandler and
kusa and Ludo shell is also strong
enough to take on several Commandments
on his own at the same time just like
with Elizabeth it is impossible to say
exactly how strong you Rochelle would be
in his own original body and since Ludo
shells power has been compared to the
goddess Elizabeth by mile it is
difficult to definitively determine
which of them is stronger I placed lunar
shell ahead of Elizabeth on this list
because even though they are both
extremely powerful in
their original bodies lunar shell has
the additional advantage of His grace
which gives him SuperSpeed and he is
also far more ruthless and aggressive
than Elizabeth
unlike Elizabeth who doesn't like
violence and she does her best to
prevent anyone from dying looter shell
is brutal and if they were ever forced
to fight to the death
ludo shells personality along with his
grace would probably give him the edge
over Elizabeth but this is just educated
speculation at this point because we
don't have enough solid information on
the goddess Elizabeth to say for sure
and then we come to the Archangel mile
the younger brother of the mass
murdering angel wife Lulu doe shell mile
is confirmed to be the strongest out of
the four Archangels and the single most
powerful warrior of the goddess clan his
strength is second only to the supreme
deity the ruler of all the goddesses
even without his grace called sunshine
which is currently possessed by eScan or
miles power level is believed to be over
200,000 and just knowing how strong s
Kannur is we can only imagine the extent
of miles power if he still had sunshine
in his possession during the previous
holy war mile strength was said to rival
even the strength of Mellie Otis and it
was only after my Elle was taken out of
the picture by the original Gotha
that the holy war finally ended because
without my hell the goddess clan could
not eliminate all the demons and they
were forced to sacrifice their own
physical bodies in order to seal the
demons away inside the coffin of eternal
darkness for 3,000 years Maya was
believed to have been killed by aster
Ossa until we later learned that my Elle
was not dead at all but I won't get into
too many details in case you're not
caught up to the manga needless to say
you definitely should read the manga
because it's absolutely amazing right
now but what really matters for the
purposes of this video is who is the
strongest and mile is definitely the
strongest member of the goddess clan
aside from one single being and that
being is the supreme deity the ruler of
all the goddesses the supreme deity is
the mother of the goddess Elizabeth and
the undisputed strongest member of the
goddess clan the supreme deity is the
only
whose power is said to be equivalent to
the demon king himself and we know that
she has some insanely overpowered
abilities for instance she has the power
to bestow Grace's upon the Archangels to
create nearly unbreakable curses such as
the one she placed on Elisabeth to
control the elements and to destroy
entire cities as was the case with belli
Alwyn the supreme deity has immunity
against all demonic curses and in
general the supreme deities light based
powers would be extremely effective
against members of the demon clan as
with the demon king we do not have an
exact power level for the supreme deity
and we haven't seen very much of her at
all as she is believed to reside in the
celestial realm however if she really is
as strong as the demon king himself then
her power level could be well over half
a million and therefore far higher than
any other power level that we have seen
to date because of Mellie Otis's various
trips to purgatory we have actually seen
the demon king in action much more than
the supreme deity but I hope that
sometime in the future we will get to
see the supreme deity demonstrate the
full extent of her power and that is it
the goddess clan and all known members
of the goddess clan ranked from weakest
to strongest thank you so much for
watching and supporting this channel and
if you'd like to support more content
like this in the future you can check
out our online store where we have
original anime inspired merch like this
praise the Sun shirt created by pro
artist weasel Monica you can also leave
a like on this video and if you're new
to the channel you can subscribe and hit
that notification Bell requests for
future videos are welcome both in the
comments and on Twitter and Instagram at
anime uproar be sure to give us a follow
and if you actually made it to the very
end of this video and didn't just click
off as soon as I said that the ranking
portion was done you can let me know by
typing hashtag goddess magnet down in
the comment as always thank you so much
for watching and until next time see us
space cowboys
[Music]
you